what I want to do in this video is show
that matrix multiplication is
associative at least I'll show it for 2
by 2 matrices and what I do in this
video you could extend it to really n
any dimension of matrices for which the
matrix multiplication is actually
defined so let's look at three matrices
so let's say this first matrix is a b c
and d and this second matrix is e f g h
and then finally this third matrix this
third matrix is i j and that's not the
imaginary unit I just just letter I i J
and this isn't e this is just letter e
JK and L and I want to look at two
scenarios so let me actually just copy
and paste this so copy and paste
so I want to look at the scenario where
first I multiply the orange and the
yellow matrix so then I multiply that
times the purple matrix and then another
scenario where first I multiply the
yellow and the purple and multiply that
times the orange and if these two
products based on how I which ones I do
first come out the same then I've just
shown that at least four three two by
two matrices that multiplication of mate
matrix multiplication is associative we
already see that it's not commutative
let's see whether it's associative and
actually I'll I'll give you the
punchline it is but let's work through
it I encourage you to actually pause the
video yourself and try to work through
it with these letters and then see if if
you've got the the result that I just
said that you you you should be getting
all right so let's multiply these first
two so this product and I'm going to
make it a little bit big so it's going
to be a e plus B G is going to a
E+ be G then AF plus BH a F plus BH and
then it's going to be C E Plus D G C
plus D G and then find it's going to be
C F Plus D H C F plus D H and we're
going to multiply it times the matrix
the matrix i j k and l and what does
this give us that I'll just give us some
space to do this with so this will give
us I give myself an ample amount of
space so it's going to be this stuff
times I so we could write this as I and
actually let me just distribute the I I
a plus I B G Plus this stuff times k
plus K a f+ k be H I'm already going to
run out of space here so let me clear
this let me just keep going and then
we're going to multiply this essentially
we're consider this row in this column
first row second column and so you are
going to have you are going to have j AE
plus j BG + + l AF l AF + l bh so these
matrices are bigger than i expected they
would be and then you're going to have
over here you're going to have this
times this Plus this times this so I see
e plus i DG + kc f plus k d h and then
finally this times this Plus this Plus
this or this times that Plus this times
that so j c e+ j DG + l c f+ l d h
alright now let's see if we can power
through this one over here so what is
what is this product going to be
this product if I multiply these two
first it's going to be e i + FK + FK +
ej and not need you sign up + this is
the next entry ej + FL ej + FL ej x + FL
then G I plus G and then we have G I
plus HK g i+ HK and then finally we have
GJ GJ + HL it's all going to be
multiplied times ABCD a b c and d and
i'm going to need some real estate to do
this so let me do it down here I'll do
it in green so let me do a little arrow
to show that this is actually I could
just Orca to scroll over a little bit
that actually might work out better so
what am I going to get so a times this
plus B times this so a e i+ a FK plus b
g i+ b HK and then you're going to have
this row in this column so it's a e j +
a FL + b GJ + b g j + b HL + b HL close
the brackets now you're going to have C
times this Plus D times this so C e i+ c
FK + D G I + D H K and then finally
homestretch C times that plus D times
this so c ej + c f l + c f l and then
you're going to have plus plus d GJ + d
HL d HL now are these two things
equivalent well let's look entry by
entry so I I II this is equivalent to a
II I because we know scalar
multiplication is commutative now i bj r
ib g ib g you see it there and you see
it there k AF you see it k f you see it
there and this is the same thing as AF k
and then k bh this is the same thing as
bh k and you could go entry by entry
actually let's just do that i'll do that
really fast so let's do so i see e is
the same thing as c e eye IDG is the
same thing as d GI k CF is the same
thing as c FK KD h is the same thing as
d HK go to the second columns je j jb g
jb g is the same thing as BG j l AF is
the same thing as AFL and lb h is the
same thing as b HL and then finally JC e
is the same thing as c ej j DG is the
same thing as DD j l EF l EF that is
that or is that LC so let's see LD h is
this right over here and so this one
must be an LC f is the same thing as cfl
is this is this one right over here in
LC f let me make sure because that would
throw a major monkey wrench into the
whole operation so this entry right over
here is going to be we get that from
multiplying the second row times the
second column and we're going to get C
see we get JC e plus j DG and then we
have LC f you have that's LC f + LD h
and so you e see that these two
quantities are the same it doesn't
matter if I multiply the first two first
and then multiply by the third or
multiply the second and third and then
multiply by the first now once again
this is the associative property I'm
keeping them essentially in the same
order order matters but as we see
depending we can associate these we can
do the first two first or we could do
the second to first